and Inferno is Raging across large parts
of Chile these are the deadliest
wildfires on record and they're
destroying everything in their path
in Santa Julia 83 year old Eduardo
Carrasco inspects what's left of the
property he's lived in his entire life
this is where the iron stove was he says
his cat and his dog were burnt alive
with everything he and his family owned
suddenly from inside and on top of the
house the Flames came there was nothing
we could do but to escape
wildfires can be fickle Don Eduardo's
watermelons and a few chickens that hid
in the vegetable patch survived
but not his two neighbors who were
engulfed By Flames when they tried to
escape
scores of people are still missing in
the nearby Hills many presume dead
these satellite images demonstrate how
much the fires have spread since Friday
a little cocktail of extreme heat strong
winds and a prolonged drought is mostly
to blame
fires are continuing to smolder all over
this area and in other parts of the Bobo
and newly region of South Central Chile
and if the winds pick up as authorities
seem to believe they will it will spread
much much further
this farmer who also lost his house
blames Tilly's powerful forestry
companies who've planted eucalyptus and
pine trees all over the region
their trees suck up all the water here
there's nothing left for us and it's
turned our land into a matchbox
still most people who've lost everything
tell us they've already dried their
tears
our country is very peculiar if we don't
get hit by earthquakes we have tsunamis
or floods and now fires so we Chileans
have learned to be resilient
Chile's government has begun receiving
assistance from its neighbors and Spain
to help exhausted firefighters
as we see more new fires emerging from
the nearby Hills it's obvious that help
can't come fast enough
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santa Juana
Chile